I love this quote there's a quote that
said do the actions of your business
match up to the promise of your brand so
to me I got really obsessed with that
right we're saying we're about hiring
the unknown what does that really mean
well it means if we keep on hiring the
same people from the same places we're
going to make the same work right stop
looking where you've always looked and
start to hire from similar places where
you might get Talent from and therefore
transform where you're going
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host heisha mizzouz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Ollie Scott he's
the founder of a recruitment business
called unknown first year we did five
six three second year 800 Grand third
year 1.2 fourth year 1.6 and big goal
for the fifth years to break two million
so in this episode we break down how
he's gone about building his business
over the last four years not only what
has worked but most importantly the
things that haven't worked we broke down
the challenges in hiring people without
experience we spoke about their
challenges in going into the US market
we spoke about leaning too much into not
wanting to be perceived as a typical
recruitment agency and the knock-on
effects that had on their business
there's so much value in this
conversation for any of you who are in
the trenches of building a recruitment
business how would you approach the
first 90 days I'm what you know now
don't do a podcast apologizing about it
enjoy this week's episode with Ollie
Ollie welcome to the podcast thank you
so much
it's like I feel like we've met at like
interesting points haven't we I feel
like obviously when I first met you
like the podcast was called the
recruitment rollercoaster podcast that
was sponsored by Hunted
so yeah I feel like I'm looking forward
to this because like we've just sort of
and then we've sort of stayed in touch
in different ways I've always sort of
seen what you've been up to so I'm
looking forward to properly like
unpacking this journey that you're on so
to give everyone some immediate content
so you're just saying so you started in
recruitment in 2012.
but what we're here to talk about today
and what we're going to dive into is the
entrepreneurial Journey that you're in
the thick of so in 2019 you started your
own recruitment business called unknown
um started this on your own with a
credit card for in Grand MBNA yeah and
first year we did five six three
four people
by the end of the year second year eight
people 800 Grand third year 1.2 10
people fourth year 1.6 14 people and big
goal for the fifth years to break 2
million
I think just because we did it this
would be really helpful as well because
then we can go into it all but in terms
of how things are currently set up and
you let me know if I've got any this
wrong obviously I've got you as the the
founder because we did a bit of an org
chart didn't we and this will just paint
a picture for everyone so obviously you
as the founder so you know people be the
brand strategy you've then got a uh your
only number your people operations
partner who you said has been an
absolute Game Changer so I'm excited to
go into that with you then you've got
four managing Partners one senior
partner who's very much just like a
biller management then the managing
Partners you have in the management uh
roles and then you know they have people
underneath them and then like I saw your
announcement video which we'll talk
about uh obviously to the US so right
now you said split the business at
around 50 UK 30 us and then the rest EU
and then products and services
contingent you've done around 50
um contingent Business 40 retained and
then you also have worked with a bunch
of companies on like team highs and
group hires so that's a real breakdown
mate I I feel like I'm about to get
sanctioned I've never I've never had my
business broken down in such a numeric
yeah sorry but we went through that
together right yeah man so everyone
listening you now have a picture of
Ollie's business I should do this when I
hope so like this but that that ever
that helps everyone right so there's a
bunch of different places we can go with
this but at least everyone immediately
has like you know they understand where
you're at yeah so where I always like to
start a million pound question which I'm
sure you've continued to wrestle with
with your own business I'd love to get
your take on you know what you believe
are the common characteristics and
traits of a
top performing recruiter in today's
market what are those in your opinion
we so we've defined this in a way
um I'm not saying we've got the for us
this is how we can find it
accountability I should I hate to be
this that direct but this is our five
values right accountability curiosity
grit see how pause that
Destiny here you've known your own five
values I'm actually gonna I'm gonna stop
there okay yeah accountability curiosity
Grit
we so we changed them right they started
off as and this is why you never do five
values right what a start to me
those are the ones I Wang on about
current we have courage which there's
this thing that we learn once around
listening right how do you listen
properly and you listen with the four
C's I always remember three of them as
I've just done with the five right
courage curiosity now those two things
are really interesting when someone says
to you how do you listen with courage
it's quite painful to listen to somebody
when they're going through a hard time
the same thing happens when you're doing
a candidate so courage for us is really
important but as is the Curiosity thing
not just I you know asking questions for
the sake of sounding clever I only ask
those questions that you really give a
about the answer to because you
know when you're asking one of those and
you're going to do it on this podcast
I'm sure right and you ask a question
you go oh you know um and you sort of
shut off when you're asking I hate that
in a recruiter so for us when we were
defining our values curiosity courage
grit grit is really important to us
because
when the times are terrible like we're
in right now this bouncy weird recession
you need to have that strange thing that
you can't Define
um and I like that I like the definition
of grit because
some I think there's a book called grit
yeah right it was it was a lot of scale
yeah but it was it was about having
persistency at the same time as passion
grit isn't helpful if you're just
persistent we all know what opposition
recruitment looks like without any
passion right the phone bashing they're
calling someone up the whole time
they're annoying people but if they have
passion alongside that that's very
different so for us grip was really
important hey they're coming back now
accountability is their baby ambition
all right okay we're here I'm back it's
funny only I think I'm out as well is
the characteristics I'll let you ask
your next question don't go for five man
go for three so if I was to pick three I
would say curiosity accountability and
grit yeah
yeah I'd say they're they're pretty
important aren't they
so let's get into this business Journey
then okay so start it on your own
I guess where I want to start is I
always I'm always curious to find out
how people like you think they're going
to do things different
you've worked in different recruitment
organizations you would have taken
things that you liked
maybe there'll be things that you don't
like and you'll be thinking right my
business I'm going to do it better than
all these experiences that I've had and
I think you've you've really lent into
that because I think I saw one of your
recent posts which said I don't want us
to look sound or smell like a
recruitment company right so one I want
to know why is that important to you and
I think that also is tied into like what
from your perspective all his
perspective when you're starting this
business and I'm sure it's evolved what
were the like one to two three things
that you're like we are going to do this
different and this is going to help us
stand out yeah okay so I I before I
thought about launching a recruitment
company I wanted to do like me on my own
right so I definitely I focused on the
market first I wanted to make sure that
I did something that wasn't like all of
the competitors we had major players and
talent business there was a bunch of
really good recruitment companies out
there I didn't want to work for any of
them but they're all saying the same
thing so firstly before I went into the
recruitment side I picked out that what
is the USC what do I want to do
differently in the recruitment Market
when it's just me I can pick anything I
chose to do the unknown proposition
which I can come on to another time but
when I started building unknown I
started to think about okay wait what
did I hate about recruitment when I
worked at the German like German there
were some brilliant things I loved about
Gemini people I tell you what I loved I
loved the culture I loved the getting
things done I love being in the team
together and pulling in the same
direction what I didn't like and the
reason why I said about the smell I
didn't like the fact that we were sort
of chucked into this office 8 AM
5 or 6 P.M every single day someone
would always cook broccoli at nine in
the morning right so it didn't smell
good to be in there the next thing would
happen you're arguing about who wants to
make kiss 100 or mellow magic right all
these weird trivial arguments that are
happening when you're not doing the job
that you're there to do 40 of people
gave a about what they did the
other 60 were there to take a pay packet
and probably become an estate agent at
some point so I didn't want to be in
that room for very long and that I
lasted six and a half years went out on
my own in this kind of Rage I hate
recruitment well recruitment's awful but
I am a recruiter right and so then when
we first set up that was the thing it's
like this can't be be anything like a
recruitment company as wank as it sounds
we work from so house and everyone no
one had a desk so what why though like
is it because you're also thinking about
I understand your experience but you're
also trying to really you know prove
externally that you're not like the rest
yeah that's totally it I also felt like
with nebulous kpis you must call 25
people today that ended up affecting the
service that you're giving to your
clients and so I saw good recruiters and
bad recruiters the bad ones that were
doing kpis for the sake of it that
persistency thing without any passion
and the good ones that were doing what
they felt what was right for their
clients that they were passionate to
work with so I knew what I didn't want
to sound like and funny if we're
speaking about kind of how to launch and
that kind of stuff one of the things
that I did when I decided to start
hiring people
I wrote a breakup letter to a
recruitment or a breakup letter to
creative Recruitment and it was it was
cheesy but it got us into this place of
of having an enemy and I think if you're
if you're going to launch a recruitment
company
you know spoiler alert the world doesn't
need another recruitment company
probably in your sector whatever it is
even if it's AI
what they do need is a company that is
different to the rest for a good reason
so when when you're thinking about doing
something differently one of the things
I found really helpful was to write a
creative breakup letter you know to the
recruitment industry and it would be
like you know I hate how you treat your
staff I hate how you kind of write fake
jobs I hate how you do all these things
that traditional bad recruitment
companies do the more we did the more I
wrote that thing and it was quite alone
like an Oscar Wilde novel The More I
started to figure out oh there's some
Trends in here that you could build a
proposition around this right and you
can hire accordingly we're the people
that we're not the people that you know
so that that to me I knew if I hired
like that and I designed our business
like that the end goal I.E the
candidates that are putting into the
jobs that we're getting on would be
better
so just to round that out then
like what I'd be curious to understand
is if you could just give us some
tangibles I understand what you're
saying that's really interesting I
haven't heard anyone talk about like
that because it's ultimately what you're
saying is in that exercise it then gave
the opportunity to reflect on the things
that you know you really liked all the
things that you didn't like and that
really then gave you Clarity on the way
that you wanted to do things that would
then be different but if we were to
you know look under the bottom of your
business right now what what would you
say you're doing different
because that that's clearly like you go
on your website doesn't it like a
recruitment website yeah because I think
that was part of your post writers like
we've been told that it looks like we're
a design agency yeah so like you've
really lent into that so I'm just really
curious to understand like the tangibles
of what is it that you do different yeah
so it's a really good question and I
didn't want to just be the guys that say
we're different and then when you work
with us you're not right I love this
quote there's a quote that said do the
actions of your business match up to the
promise of your brand so to me I got
really obsessed with that right we're
saying we're about hiring the unknown
what does that really mean well it means
if we keep on hiring the same people
from the same places we're going to make
the same work right so to our clients
the proposition was very clear stop
looking where you've always looked and
start to hire from similar places where
you might get Talent from and therefore
transform where you're going right in
other words the mystery box option right
so we would say to our clients when we
build short lists it's 75 of what you're
expecting to see and 25 of what the
where did that come from right and
interestingly a lot of the time the what
the they normally get the job
because the client would look at the
candidate and go yeah you have said
everyone from our competitors yeah I
knew I knew Dave I knew Daisy I knew
Peter that other person though why did
you send that person well you know we've
noticed that you guys have been doing a
lot of X and this person has done a lot
of X but now they've started doing why
so if you went for that person you could
win way more clients and so you start to
the proposition becomes around
transformation
via the root of diversity so what we're
doing differently we're looking at
business problems rather than briefs
we're not we're not going give us a
brief give us the job role and the
criteria we're looking beyond that and
we're saying to them right before we
even get into this briefing stage before
you send me a job spec for the first
year I was like don't send me a job spec
because you've already arrived at your
solution which is a higher it's going to
be a designer for that brand talk to me
about the problem in your business and I
can start to figure out if you need to
hire somebody could come from internally
probably won't and be where is the
opportunity here because you can you're
telling me there is a problem there is a
gap in your business it may not be in
the place that you think it is
okay that's that's super interesting and
I love I love the the focus on the the
problems piece because that can
transform a lot of
recruiters success if you're listening
to this and
I quote the a sound bot that I really
like so uh amber Penrose he's been on
this podcast is very it was a very
popular one
she did a training session with us and
it's always stuck with me and like this
is how I approach sales as well and it
is again just transformative and I think
actually the right way to go about it if
I'm honest so
the sound bite from Amber was what made
her go from a 500 gram Bill to an 800
gram biller where she stopped chasing
vacancies and she only chased problems
nice
and like it's just a really easy way to
remember that so what we're saying here
is okay yes there is you need someone
there's a job brief here right now but
be willing to say okay Ollie let's just
take a step back for a moment like why
why why have we got here why is this
important why do we need to get this
person what's gonna happen if you don't
get this person and you actually have
those types of conversations it's
questions as well and I think if you
were to ask like because that's all well
and good saying go hunting for the
problems but to get privy to the
problems is the is the hard part you
know if I said to my associates who are
just starting out recruitment go find
some problems I they'd get there in the
end because they'd follow leads and they
figure out but if they're in front of a
client it's quite scary to ask a client
the questions that unlock those problems
so I tried to get those into two key
questions that I actually think are
important with anything in any task that
you're given let alone a brief
um one of them is and it sounds so basic
but what is the purpose of this hire
that you're trying to make right now
like to give me I'm going to ask you why
five times you're gonna say because the
client's gonna leave and can I ask you
why again well because if we haven't got
that client we can't then you travel up
the Y tree and you end up finding out
that my co-founder hates design
and I've got to get somebody to convince
them to stay right yeah so then you go
right well it's probably not that that
Junior is probably someone that's more
senior now so number one is is what is
the purpose of this hire and traveling
out and asking why five times and the
second question is
how are we going to measure its impact
once it arrives within your business
because that's when you under you
understand the truth you know a lot of
clients come to you and they get they go
they almost have the idea around the
hire they'll be like oh yeah you know
it's someone that's going to be bad bad
all these executions right and you go
great and then how are you going to
measure when they're in the business
well the truth is we haven't actually
got that business on at the moment so
you start to sort of the text
when you ask them how they're going to
measure the impact of this champagne
high that they're trying to get you to
make with them
I love that what is the purpose and and
what how are we going to measure the
success of this person yeah great
questions uh okay so one of the the
fundamental ways then that use uh
obviously approach being different is I
really like that so tapping into talent
that can often be missed
overlooked and then the the benefits of
that so yeah it's diversity then it
sounds like but not in a bad way when
you said because I was going to call uh
unknown was going to be called unheard
okay right and I was all in the ends I
was going you know undiscovered and they
all have really negative connotations
when you say to somebody you're selling
the idea of diversity and you're saying
to them have you considered the
overlooked people yeah so the the name
has to be empowering unknown is
well that's fomo I've got fomo what if I
well if I don't know the best person for
this brief you know and that works both
ways for the candidates I want to go to
x agency or brand okay cool there are
obvious choices there but what about the
places that you don't know have you
considered X and the unknown name drives
fomo but also curiosity from both
clients and candidates where where can I
go then and then you build trust because
you're not just saying all the best
places in the world that they can go to
so any on on this then just curious any
like house
worth sharing on how you go about doing
that
finding the people yeah like because I I
it's it sounds great yeah like how did
you go about doing that is it just
I don't know like are you then
showcasing people that don't quite fit
all the things they're looking for but
you have a compelling reason as to like
why like how so firstly it's back to
that brief right you know understanding
the real business problem and by the way
when I say the unknown and the
overlooked people I'm not talking
Postman for creative director roles
right I'm talking like we're like five
degrees away yeah I don't just go oh by
the way here's here's a banger dancer
and I think they're brilliant what they
do it can sound like that yeah that's
what somebody want and this was really
offensive one of our clients said to us
we were pitching for a really a CEO role
you know we've only done four or five of
those searches in our in our time at
that point and um the the chairman said
this unknown lot or is it like wonky
fruit
so is it like dashboards you know that's
what I was like no no no no it's not
that it's transformative so yeah good
question yeah wonky through brilliant I
can't believe her name for that so so
yeah we sort of focused around that
really and we're like right okay so
there's one thing saying that we hire
different people it's not just different
for the sake of different and I think
that's the important conversation when
it comes to diversity it's
transformation when the only way you can
really transform is a getting really
good at the basics so
if you have these business problems I'm
not going to send you somebody that's a
really sexy hire that has no idea how to
do the day-to-day of your business they
will understand your business it's just
there a bit further down the line in
their career probably at one of your
better competitors doing something that
you wish you were doing so these are
people that are going to help companies
transform not here's a random person
that's going to come in and we'll see if
it works out good luck because I think
that's where that's where our
proposition got a little bit murky and I
had I have to keep on qualifying that on
my LinkedIn at the moment because the
more people go wait so what is it oh
can't you just send me like who I want
you know yes we will that's part of the
proposition but what about the people
that you know that you could go for that
are going to help you transform so the
answer to your question very long answer
is deeply understanding very specialist
markets we're hyper Niche you know where
we have normally where people have about
one person we have about eight people
covering design and So within that
design you've got product ux UI branding
in those designs so by knowing those
fields intricately well and knowing
exactly who is out there when they're
going to move and all that stuff then
you can start to look at the the unknown
I hate to quote people but there is a
Picasso quote that has arrived in my
brain at this point okay
I can remember it I love my values I'm
gonna remember this one he says give me
give me the rules so I can learn them
like a pro and break them like an artist
right and I kind of see that in
candidate mapping right you look at your
all of the candidates in your market and
you learn them like a pro and it's only
then that you can start to suggest the
the wonky fruit right
as well as I feel like as well though
what's fundamental which you've touched
on is
being uh curious enough to find out the
the tree problems yeah exactly because
that's when you can that's when you're
going to have a compelling reason as to
like why they're part of the shortlist
yeah because you've listened you've
actually asked some questions around
what's the purpose of this person what
how you're going to measure the success
of them so if you're doing that
effectively yeah then you're going to
have yeah you're not then just like
speaking to ollie and making sure he
ticks all the boxes on the job
description you actually understand how
this person can transform their their
business as you said your previous guest
from Adecco I forget her name now I mean
Amy she was speaking about
um one of the things that I I stand by
massively and that is being brave enough
to say why someone's not right for your
role and still submitting them right
you're being a consultant and she was
she was saying on the podcast right
you're looking at somebody and you're
going I call it sitting on the Park
Bench rather than you know how most
sales that we're right now it's like
this is why they're great everyone's
amazing they're banging they're
brilliant that breeds distrust after a
while when you send seven people people
and three of them are right
you say everyone's amazing how can I
believe anything you say so Having the
courage to say to a client like Amy was
saying
look here's here's Dave
um or Daisy we'll go with Daisy you know
she's brilliant for these reasons I've
just got this slight doubt and it might
not be a real doubt but I'm just gonna
flag it now by being willing enough to
sit on the park bench and look at the
candidate as a holistic being rather
than a product that you're trying to
sell somebody it changes the dynamic in
the relationship that you have with your
client immediately Because by the way if
you don't say that in the write-up might
not be right for these reasons they're
gonna find out you can't pull the ball
over somebody's eyes right so yeah
that's one of the things that we do
differently
awesome no I appreciate you going into
that because I think that that can
definitely spark some ideas and I think
people appreciate it because we all hear
how people are different right which is
what I wanted to
to go there where where I wanted to go
now because I feel like a lot of people
could learn from this was you shared to
me how you've had to learn the hardware
around being nice and being kind okay
talks about what what that looks like
what that means because I think
particularly in markets right now as a
business owner
as a manager as a leader
it's when things are tough it's it is it
can be hard to have that balance of like
being empathetic and then also
being like well this is required sort of
things you know I mean that line is
sometimes difficult so talks about being
nice and being kind and what you had to
learn the hard way yeah quick
um context I think is important on this
I I obviously wrote to Gemini people it
was a great company James carnon I
everyone in that business was subject to
hot and cold management right when
you're billing everyone loves you when
you're not no one does so when I started
to hire people for unknown I didn't want
anyone to ever experience that because
anything it was a really toxic way of
being being managed so much so that I
went the other way right so and I and
you know I had lots of therapy before I
started the business we have a group
therapists that are known and I implore
everybody that was the whole thing I
want to get everyone therapists so house
memberships and class pass we're
gonna just look out for everyone
everyone's lives right whether their
shit's all good we'll look after their
lives right so I just I had this dying
thing because I'm I don't know if you
know what a codependent means but I want
people to like me right and I don't like
it if you don't like me and it's like a
you know it's a weakness and a strength
at the same time it's definitely a
weakness when you're trying to run a
company with slow yeah with people that
aren't performing right number one I was
just nice I go no it's all right it will
work out you know Just Keep On Believing
and have that kind of American blind
optimistic view on people development
without defining where or how they could
get to that place right so that was the
biggest learning I said to everybody I
went on a podcast and I said it you
know kpis are rubbish they're just
nebulous they're pointless we don't do
them one idiot right what we do do is
objective chaos which I think everybody
does okrs right but the nice versus kind
of thing the kind thing to do in a
situation when someone's joined you
isn't to say go get a tiger and hunt out
a 15th Place medal it's to go to
them right here's the games of the you
know here the other rules of the game
this is how you win this is how you
exceed and if you're not doing those
things come to me and I will tell you
how to get better and designing a space
of feedback and all that kind of stuff I
just I feared systems I didn't like the
rigidity of you know Monday cool setting
objectives Friday call how do we get on
I just thought these kids aren't babies
they know what they're doing and the
first five people did know what they
were doing because they'd been burned by
the place that we come from and when you
first start a recruitment company you
don't usually hire Junior people which I
didn't I thought I was pretty senior
recruiters and the magic worked no kpis
we'd even speak about numbers we
were just making enough money yeah then
we got the next wave of people in who I
thought okay let's go Associates we can
we've got the Midas touch we'll just
teach these guys how to do recruitment
by osmosis and it didn't work we had
people in the business that we weren't
being kind to by being clear we were
just being nebulous and random and
supportive but not really telling people
what they should and shouldn't do to be
a successful recruiter and that that
comes from me you know there's trying to
be different can polarize right trying
to trying to be different is really
important in the early days you've got
to establish a culture by starting a
revolution around something but that can
become polarized and bad when it starts
to eat away at what you set up the
company to do so my belief on being
different started to become bad for the
business yeah because I wasn't being
kind and clear to the recruiters that
have joined us that had no I was saying
rip out the rule book that you know what
rule book I've never read it you know so
so what that meant and you know the
reason I said being Converse is being
nice is it's you could be nice all your
career and you could be crap you'd be a
really really nice leader and you can be
really bad but to be a kind leader is
very different and being kind isn't
always being nice being kind can mean
being pretty brutally honest
about someone or being right for your
business yeah before it gets too late
before they start pissing you off and
pissing other people off because they're
not pulling their weight the kind thing
to do in that situation is to go hey
this isn't how how do you think this is
working out you know do you really want
to be are you enjoying this because the
way this is going to go from no one
which is going to get quite messy that's
a kind thing to do the the nice thing
that I probably did in that situation
um was to plot along and when it got
really really bad
boom gunshots at the back of the head
this isn't working sorry like that
that's such a difference it's a really
unkind way of and that happens in every
recruitment company
you know you have this kind of passive
aggressive manager that sort of half
tells you you're doing badly but doesn't
want to piss you off because it's
awkward and then lo and behold two
months down the line you've not hit your
target you're gone and you never had
that Clarity nobody ever told you
because they weren't bothering to be
kind they were just being nice so that's
my point on nice versus kind yeah I
think just a quick point on that and
then I'm gonna ask you to just paint a
picture for us on what it looked like
and then maybe what it looks like now
because I think that'd be really
interesting for people but I just want
to caveat with what you just said I I
definitely agree but actually because
because of what we do we have a lot of
those managers you're describing like
deliver training for us because a lot of
the time they've got to that seat by
being good performers often top
performers but a lot of those people
actually get all help on how to be
kind yeah on how to be a coach on how to
listen effectively on how to communicate
feedback like so it's also that there's
also a huge element there where just so
many people don't get any support or
help on how like how to actually be
better do you know what I mean I mean
that's why I was interested when I saw
your product yeah because that's a big
way how remote like how we incentivize
people to deliver training at the core
of our offer is you get put through a
coach accelerator course and that is
what people are most excited about
compared to the money but like what I'd
love you to share you touched on it
because I've spoke to a lot of
recruitment leaders that have probably
gone through what you've gone through
they sort of panned I there's a way that
I've been saying it is they've probably
pandered too much to what employees
wanted yeah
and it but it sounded like Ollie just
pandered to like I wanted everyone to
like really enjoy work and I want
everyone to like me and all that right I
I get that but I think a lot of
recruitment leaders went too far the
other way and then when things have got
more difficult because they didn't have
anything like
you know measuring things or they
weren't hot on any of those things it's
then really difficult to help people get
better because there's there's not
there's like nothing to look at but it's
also then difficult to communicate
you're also wrestling with well no no I
we still want the side hosts the Soho
House stuff we want the class pass we
want to be supportive
um but how do we then now communicate
that look you can still have that but I
need you to be on it and like
have a bit more of that energy rather
than like oh it's okay like you know I
hold myself accountable I didn't get the
shortlist done whatever I'll do it next
week sort of thing yeah so what did
things look like before yep
so you said there like something on
Monday something on Friday
like we already whatever so that what it
looked like before where maybe you felt
like you lent too much to like it was
too much to them I was being too nice to
then how have you then like combined
that because I'm sure it's not just gone
all the way the other way have you then
blended it so what did it look like
initially because I think people could
relate to that and then what does it
look like now so number one we I wrote
the values I wrote the principles I
wrote everything right and I just went
they are but uh and I expected everybody
to work and live with them right that's
not how you implement values into a
business so we worked my head at that
time we looked like a values-led
business I thought and then things would
happen I'd be like why the that's
not how we were so I need to bring them
along on the journey I needed to do a
values Workshop a purpose Workshop
um that was the first thing we kicked in
right so one thing I will say like
Monday and Friday what the context of
those meetings are different before they
were very much like what are you going
to try and do this week yeah yeah that's
what I wanna know about what they
sounded like but back then it was very
much like I I still I believe in
intention and reflection that's how I do
on Monday and Friday cool and it would
the intentions were fee and they weren't
around our principles or values and they
were just like what are you going to get
done this week right so very again I use
the word nebulous a lot but objective
lists kind of calls and conversations
but I'll go back a little bit because
I've realized that last maybe two years
ago the beginning of this year when I
hired our people operations partner I
said to her we have a problem and that
is that people say they are doing things
that they are not to appease right and
so therefore we need to find a way where
people aren't forgetting these values
and they're living and breathing what we
stand for as a business so what we did
we did a purpose workshop for those who
don't know you sit around a room and you
figure out what you stand for and what
you're trying to achieve and then from
that
um we decided to bring in the rest of
the business once we had a clear
understanding of who we were what our
key values were which I remember four
out of them now again the fifth One's
Gonna Come Back
um I think we're gonna boil them down to
three and then the principles which I
think are really important before
writing the principles if you've seen
the Nike film air yeah there's some
greatest 10 principles in there I wrote
them before I saw that by the way will
say
um but we wrote 10 principles but I
didn't want to do that until the rest of
the business had come in into a little
we Hideout space and I said okay guys
here's what you want to achieve in three
years time we're going to be a company
of 25 people healthy happy High earning
High performing humans that's the the
purpose
um and then at the same time I want us
to get there whilst having a lot of fun
right here are the key values that we
stand for now what I want to do and this
is how this idea my people operations
partner she made it up yeah it worked
for us yeah we we got everyone to break
out into different teams of three and we
said right you've got one person in that
three and they are going to be like the
most unknown as in our company unknown
unknownian as we call them yeah they're
a pure annonium right here are
20 Post-it notes write down the
behaviors that make that person the
purest unian right so it's like you know
he gets back to candidates he lets
people down gently but it's always you
know kind of the behaviors of a good
recruiter essentially and then the
things we do Now flip him we literally
had someone standing up and we flipped
them right it was a bit pervy
um it was Joe though he was a bloke and
he was all right with it so Joey was
standing up and he was like right we
turned Joe around and we're like right
on Joe's back I want you to write what
are the unacceptable behaviors of an
unknownian what does a bad unknownian do
they they're ghost candidates
um they write fake jobs
what you're doing is you're starting
tribalism in the business yeah you're
kind of going right you're all there
that day you wrote on a posting that and
stuck on his back why have you done it
you know so then from that I took all
the Post-it notes with Hannah we
scattered them across the table yeah and
I wrote The 10 principles that we all
stood by and believed in and then to get
the principles to be married into the
business every Monday every Friday I
would say right the principal is this
one how are you going to show up to that
principle this week and then on the
Friday I would say how did you show up
to that principle
and so you've gone from the top all the
way through then on to a regular basis
where you're reporting back on the
things that you believe and the company
say they stand for and you show examples
like one of our thing is clarify up
front otherwise it gets awkward
and somebody will say yeah so I had a
client call and the client was trying to
pitch that they wanted to hire This
brilliant person I said can I just
clarify what is the business problem
that they're coming in to solve and the
client couldn't answer so I didn't take
the brief
I was like oh man you know but that's
good we've we've saved time right we
didn't take an uh a ghost brief that was
never going to work because you've lived
by one of our principals and now the
whole company know about that
so it's a long answer to your question
but I believe the way that you get to
begin you know having a company that is
operating better than how we were is
starting with what matters and What
Makes You Different
um I can go into the operational stuff
yeah we're going no I think that like
what's really helpful about there is you
you just shared how because that that
came after that there was then changes
but the changes came from everyone being
involved in those changes because I
think as a business owner or you know
how many of you start a business and
then you're like you know what I think
we've actually gone too far this way and
we probably need to get back to like
more this if you then just go into the
office next day and like right guys
and then you're like what the like now I
joined this because it was like no kpis
like that so it's like how can I
approach that and what I really liked
what you shared there is like you said
they they put the Post-it notes on that
person's back yeah they they did so then
when you were holding these people
accountable and they're not doing you
know they're not living by the
principles
you go you can't really defend that
really yeah because I put the Post-it
note on that person's back yeah but the
good thing is right and the thing is one
of the things about culture that nobody
says is it's a little bumpy journey to
know what you know what the culture is
we I have gone against a load of those
Post-it notes but then I I'm
giving people permission to hold me
accountable to that and go uh did you
clarify like no I didn't know you're
right so I think that's why people go
wrong sometimes they get these
principles and they hold them so
tightly and they're like right you're
not doing the thing and then people go I
don't want to be here anymore it's weird
so I think that's key you know yes
holding people accountable but also
being forgiving when things do go wrong
uh and and sharing with everybody we
have voice note it was voice note
Tuesday when everyone sends them in like
hey guys I went against one of our
principles by doing this up but
I'm one of our things is to be
accountable so I'm letting you all know
this podcast is proudly partnered with
vincere the all-in-one recruitment
agency software that over 20 000
recruiters trust daily we're also
partnered with the award-winning one-up
sales and motivation platform that
enables you to maximize the potential of
your teams we love partnering with both
of these organizations because they
share our and helping you get the most
out of your people and your business you
can get exclusive offers because you
listen to this podcast and get up to 10
of the usage price forever use a link in
the show notes to get your hands on that
let's get back to the episode
so I feel like I want to make sure we
cut this because I feel like this also
really helpful people but I feel like
we've spoken about there because one of
the things that you shared that you know
if you was listening to this and you was
like a couple of years into the business
Journey the people management element
and these things like would be you'd
really love to like learn more about
yeah
so I want to like is that why don't we
as we're talking about it because I want
you to talk about and share how
you got caught maybe again too much one
way or thinking I'm a business owner I
need to be on the business not in the
business and like your journey with
actually recognizing and understanding
where you can have the biggest leverage
and impact on the business right so what
I wanted to talk about that but I guess
very uh quickly like you shared me how
important this people operations partner
has been in your business so clearly you
were referencing her there in terms of
helping you execute things like that
where maybe you said to her like you
said we've got this problem and then she
helps you execute right what else like
how else is this massively you know
helped your business from an operation
standpoint because I think I've shared
this a lot but definitely a common trend
on why recruitment companies in the UK a
lot of them are micro businesses under
10 people is they don't have often don't
invest in the processes the systems for
them to be 20 and 25 30 because they
think oh we'll just worry about that
when we get there yeah but you've got
this you know the non-billard person in
there so what what else have they been
hugely valuable for in terms of helping
you get this business ready to be a 25
person company yeah so Hannah I agree by
the way we were early I got to 12 over
13 people I think we were maybe maybe
more 14 whatever and normally people say
yeah 2025 is a good time to to appoint
somebody at that point I I really
disagree if you can afford to get
somebody and that's an onbuilder at that
point you should one because you need to
be more on the business and figure out
what you're bad and good at for a long
time I was doing the wrong job I was
just doing reviews and feeding back on
problems that were happening the whole
time so I spotted that I was getting
pulled into stuff that I just it wasn't
helping the business and I could see our
clients weren't hearing from me very
regularly and all that sort of stuff so
what I did the process I wrote down what
are all of the things that if I could
just give to somebody else I would you
know counting conversations reviews
um to be honest a lot of the people's
stuff that I don't need to know about
that are happening you know squabbles
whatever it is I wrote this list of
things down and the thing about that is
that's not enough to then go who wants
to do this all this terrible stuff that
I hate so I was like okay let's break
this into a few different sections some
of these things are people things and a
lot of these things are operational
things so I don't need a HR Director I
don't need an operations manager I need
a bit of a blend between those two but I
want them to be really good and
I want them to come here and and their
career will get better if they come here
so I knew I had to offer something other
than just doing the stuff I didn't like
doing and that's why I called it a
people operations partner because the
partner stuff is the thing that is why
Hannah joined my Business Partnership
stuff is like how do we start to design
better board packs how do we build a
better board for the business go out and
meet people how we're going to expand to
the US you know all the growth stuff
that a HR Director probably wouldn't
have been involved in
um I involved her in that why so early
because I I want to build a recruitment
company with a power like
brilliant culture yeah I love how I love
having people that I enjoy being around
in the business
cannot do that I think Beyond 15 people
on your own and so I wanted to get
somebody that yes of course without the
operational stuff that gives me a
headache yes that takes over the people
side of things and also do the
partnership stuff but really it's to
make sure the people are happy and
healthy and looked after because people
don't tell you the truth as much that's
the thing once you get to founder I've
not called myself a CEO yet but that's
on the cards to be soon I'm gonna
promote myself as that by the way I'll
come on to that I didn't I again
imposter syndrome whatever you want to
call it I didn't call myself a
CEO at the beginning because
and then when we got the 15 I had Hannah
she came and we started you know started
to make progress on our reviews we wrote
roles and responsibilities now that is a
key key thing
wow that is important roles
responsibilities and also promotional
criteria to get up with it sounds so
basic but like listing down what is
expected of the employees and what is
the unexpected how do you exceed your
job so she came in she's smashed a lot
of that stuff we're now I guess going
from the um get her getting in the boat
phase to now ruining it you know she's
going right okay I get it people trust
me in this business and now we can move
forward
um but that I mean God where do I start
with how many things that she's done
with this business I think I think about
London is that okay yeah I think yeah I
learned a lot of it uh I really again
there's some really practical tasks
there on like Yeah The Rose
responsibilities you firstly reflecting
on the things that you think actually
isn't the best quite best use of your
time or yeah it isn't going to help you
keep the business going the right
direction
so and then do you feel like just
curious and find a bit on that do you
think that one person because you've
done it that way do you think she could
then execute all the things that in that
you need them to execute up to like 20
people or do you see that team needing
to be bigger or do you reckon you've got
that personality we've got all these
things in place now where like there's
gonna be a lot less things that break
going get into 20. yeah I think I
actually think
I always said oh I don't want to get any
bigger than 25 in the UK because it
happens when the broccoli starts
um I I don't see why she couldn't do
that yeah my biggest thing at the moment
is trying to figure out something which
I'll be really open about
I'm going to New York next year the plan
is for me to go out there for a bit
longer like two and a half months whilst
we're applying for a Visa
um can she and the managing Partners run
the business successfully with me being
completely off that time zone yeah
um and that's the litmus test really is
like does it go to and you know
when I go away I've been away for like
two weeks last last year Hannah was a
month in and I genuinely felt we did one
voice note in that two weeks and I was
okay that's awesome and like I wanna
okay sure the things have stagnated
there's things that I move along that
just won't happen other way unless I'm
there but operationally and financially
everything was okay yeah so I wanna yeah
the goal really is to get to that point
where I'm I'm just adding I'm Top Line
yeah someone once said to me this advice
when I was moving from being founded to
CEO and that will eventually happen
officially but he said this really
impressive thing which I've kind of
lived by
I wrote to him and I was like I feel
really guilty I'm sitting in a sauna and
it's 3 P.M on a Monday
and um I feel like I should be doing new
business or you know finding candidates
or whatever
um I went to this weird time where I
just busied myself I just call the
biller and be like enjoy any help with
anything right what happened like I've
replaced I'd made myself redundant right
my old job was redundant we got to about
nine or ten people
uh nine on ten people you you I stopped
billing I wasn't doing I wasn't doing
any business development I was I don't
want to get in their way I just went
right I'm brand guy I mean Hannah was
there or not no she wasn't there at that
time but this guy who's been a CEO for
25 years
um said to me you're the reason you're
struggling right now is that you're
thinking about the next three months
that's not your job anymore you've been
doing that for the last two years your
job is to think about what happens in
nine months your head needs to be in
nine months you've got the cash flow and
the luxury to do that so make sure that
you buy service to your business you're
always in the nine months ahead and
that's that was kind of freeing for me I
was allowed to then sit in a sauna at 3
P.M on a Monday whilst I'm not billing
going right and that incredibly you then
become a top-line leader you've got
bottom line leaders and top-line leaders
they're both as important as each other
bottom line of the guys going to make
payday into the month is the CRM working
is all the stuff ticking along that
actually reduced costs right in a
recession these are the CEOs these are
the CFOs that come out of the woodwork
going right it's my time to shine how do
we minimize expenditure the Top Line
CEOs usually are the guys that are going
where are we going to be in nine months
time what is the next opportunity that's
going to come in and how can I win that
for our business so we're celebrating
that in nine months time yeah so that
that was really freeing and I think once
and it's really important to say once
you aren't worried about the next three
months you can do that job if you're
still looking at your Runway and going
we're not going to make it past the next
six weeks we need to crack on you before
you get down to the bottom line and you
do the top line as well no I think
that's really helpful People Mate
because like you'll you'll have
you'll have friends I think although I
know you don't like you know all the
recruitment circles but I don't dislike
it I just I I had to be angry at it yeah
like the reason why I mention that is
because I think what you're talking
about there is the mindset sometimes
people never get out of like they just
have the because they came from there
was a top biller they did all that now
they start their own business it's like
well I'll just keep doing deals map like
you know smashing those things in that's
how can I help the business but then you
know where they probably then struggle
to scale is they don't have those as
that Epiphany yeah right where it's like
actually how can I actually now best
serve this business we've got the nine
month Runway the 12 month Financial
Runway actually no I'll just keep doing
deals like that like makes me feel good
like I like being in the leaderboard you
know what I mean so I think that'd be
really helpful for people so in line
with that then what is it that now all
the views he can do that best serves the
business to be a Top Line leader what is
it now that because you broke this down
with me didn't you like what have you
arrived at I know it always evolved yeah
yeah but okay I'm no longer billing I've
made myself redundant I've got a hand in
the operations person
like I need to be doing more than just
you know my sauna and cold Plunge in the
afternoon like what what is it that
you're then doing that you believe is
like I'm moving this this business
forward yeah so I went back to what I
love doing it's important to say that
like there are things that I do for the
business that I I would always love and
that is business development getting in
front of clients right I think you know
I needed to carry on doing that and I
stopped I'll be honest for 18 months
didn't meet a client just well that's
not my thing anymore so dumb right I I
so you wouldn't do that I just wouldn't
uh you know if you were to start that
Journey do not do that right Gary
vaynerchuk he always speaks about the
Inside Out CEO right inside out CEO is
in the client conversations he is
hosting them at the Monday to Friday
conversations and figure out what the
going on within the business you
are in the business but the way that you
work on the business is by doing the
thing that you do brilliantly and better
than anybody else in that company which
in my case writing really good content
hosting podcasts and meeting CEOs and
then what I do is I choose find I think
that's one of the most important things
to see over recruitment company should
do what are the trends and the truths
that are happening you're only going to
get them from really honest
conversations with leaders and your
clients so go for park bench
conversations that sounds a bit weird
creepy gopher get well metaphorically
part bench conversations where you're
not selling out the client you're
looking at them and going what do you
see in the market what are you you know
how how are you how can I help you how
are you navigating through this storm
and then you get the information so I
think my job really is to be this kind
of detective finding out all the truths
and the trends that are happening in the
industry writing about them publicly so
we are known as the business that knows
what's going on not being you know
closeting information from the industry
and then I guess the other part of my
job is the people development stuff and
it's the kind of things that made me
successful as a recruiter and reminding
I listened to that podcast literally
this morning by the way and Amy yeah I
sent it to my whole business and
I was like I've not heard recruitment
like this for so long this is beautiful
it's so she was so simplistic and she
like in a good way yeah and and
operationally minded those things like
enriching processes I can't even say in
that but like reminding everybody of how
to get things done with the most amount
of Leverage right and going right let's
look at these situations so I think yeah
on the business stuff is BD and seeing
clients and podcasting and writing about
it and then in the business is trying to
deepen and enrich my management team
team and everybody else in the company
as well in being best practice and
asking like we do these fear well I say
we do we're about to do these fear
Fridays or fear Thursdays fear Thursdays
maybe
and that is when we sit around you know
in a circle Kumbaya and people come with
a thing that they're worried about or
they think they're out and they go
look I'm really bad at writing BD
messages how do you do Beauty well I I
don't know how to prep a candidate for
an interview how do you do that I'm just
starting that now we're starting that
now we've done it you know we do it on
voice notes it's not the same so now I
love a voice note I love my
voice
yeah I'm all for voice notes but I've
got a 1.5 of them two percent brother
two sorry two x that's the only thing
about LinkedIn voice notes like you
can't I don't think you can speed them
up there's a bit jarring oh they're only
going for a minute though that's a good
thing yeah I want to be able to fast
forward it man because people just long
things at home I don't think people
should do in voice notes on LinkedIn
it's aggressive yeah okay so you've got
voice night Tuesdays voice night
Thursday yeah yeah but yeah okay so you
what I love about that we speak to a lot
of customers around this is like you're
definitely been me like I know you've
done the voice note but what you're
creating there is a lot of companies
don't create an intentional space for
their team to learn from others it's
actually great it's actually wild yeah
like I said it's one of my friends the
other day who's in recruitment I was
like just curious your top biller do you
think that like every like if they're if
they've got like a an Outreach email or
like a spec template that they've been
using for the last two months that is
always getting a bite do you think James
and your team uh also knows about that
no yeah often the answer right it's like
creating this intentional space to go
what's working for you ollie this is
what's what's working for me like this
is these are things I'm really finding
working on the phone right now like
that's a missed opportunity you have to
create that intentional space for people
to do that in a lot of sharing amongst
their team it's hot by the way we've not
cracked that as well because we
because we're trying to stand out and be
different the new people that join it's
kind of a bit clicky it's quite culty so
new recruiters are going I don't know if
I should say that I'm not going to share
what I've done because it might not be
the unknown way which is my least
favorite thing because I'm like hey
there's not an unknown way where
everyone's got to be we're not you know
Russia here we're not trying to make
everybody that's a communistic sort of
vibe here it's we're trying to make sure
everybody can sound like themselves they
have permission to sound like whatever
they want to sound like ideally them
themselves right the unknown way is just
is becoming curious about how you can
sound better but it's impossible to
expect people to be like that unless
you've created a safe psychological
space where people feel like they're not
going to get judged that's true and and
you know I was thinking about that fear
thing that's one of the weirdest things
like I it's so hard and this is a really
it's an art to nail the feedback thing
you know I see a post that flies out
that I've not proof read and I'll go
that's not how we should sound at
all that's awful I had to find a way to
write to that person that I know and go
hey I I really love the intention of
what you've written here but we don't
say things like that and you know just
try and change it that's really hard
because you're trying to get everyone to
sound like themselves but not like that
right yeah so it's a fine it's a really
fine balance and it would be impossible
to achieve if you don't establish
vulnerability and a welcomeness to that
right yeah let's all be okay with being
wrong I'm gonna share when I'm wrong and
yeah yeah okay right last five to seven
minutes then and that's gone quick last
five to seven minutes because I want to
make sure we're touching it because
you're in the thick of it so let me let
me just hit you with how long have you
been in the thick of building Traction
in the US would you say a year and a
half year and a half Okay cool so what
I'd love you to for us to end on then
you've got a year and a half con of
context
for people listening that might be early
on on the journey or considering
expanding into the US whatever from what
you've learned so far
how would you approach the first 90 days
knowing what you know now don't do a
podcast apologizing about going to the
US okay uh the British charm thing yeah
works but the
apologetically British thing doesn't
work right and the kind of vulnerability
thing which works for us really well
here doesn't work there so what does
that look like what does that sound like
I.E um you know
in in the UK we don't like sales right
so you've got to find a clever way of
getting someone to get in bed with you
no metaphorically
in New York they want to know what
they're buying right really
quickly right don't tell me that this is
a chat right tell me what you do and
tell me how you're going to help me yeah
like the whole Gary vaynerchuk jab jab
right hook thing is true you give
something away you give something away
then you write hook and you go hey I do
this I really want to have a
conversation with you about that
totally the other thing I would do in 90
days ask for introductions they will
give them freely and then give them to
them as well from people that you you
chat exactly if you're in London you're
having a call with them you go right get
to the point make it about them ask them
all the questions like what would they
dream to be working where would they
love to be or you know who they love to
hire or whatever it is get to the nut
but more importantly who have they not
got in their Network that they would
like to have in their Network show off
that you know people show off that you
could you know because it's New York is
that in New York particularly is like
that LA's a bit Frosty when it's it's
more like who do you know in New York
it's how can I help you know someone
right so the thing that we learned quite
early on is to add value as soon as we
got somewhere and we go oh yeah you've
again the transformation thing you
mentioned that you might want to do this
one day with your career have you spoken
to Jenny she's really good at that yeah
cool I'll hook you up so every meeting
you have don't leave without offering at
least an introduction is one of the
things that we learned
um all right introductions yeah and
value and if we're talking about
startups going to the us we we still
haven't Incorporated I nearly
Incorporated early on
um but we didn't decide to do that in
the end you don't need to until you want
to have people on the ground right um
the other thing is if you have a brand
trademark it uh because we got sued as
soon as we got there uh literally that's
all good though right it's all good we
sorted out I got yeah yeah let's talk
about that seasoned assist yeah that's
not an interesting that's heavy
yeah it literally said you must stop
using the word unknown in everything it
was like but we've given you enough time
using unknown but now a reservoir of
good words yeah we've given you a
reservoir of Goodwill enough anyway
so don't don't do that and if you have a
brand that's distinctive like cherish it
and protect it
um be like be very clear about what
you're adding to that market and don't
and the it's a Rizzy Market or because
there's loads of money here it's
obviously not gonna fly you have to have
something distinctive that you're
bringing that's different so when we
first went there the 90 days it was just
curiosity we almost I can zipped our
mouths closed and just open our ears and
we're like okay what is what would you
change about this Market where do you
think there is a lack and we we
discovered there was a big black in mid
to see new talent because of covid we
went there literally the six months
after kovid the one thing everyone was
screaming about was culture I really
miss having that kind of culture and you
know I'd love to work within an office
so you start to figure out we can add
something now it's not got to be some
big entrepreneurial discovery about the
market it can be a timely Discovery it
can be a thing where you're like oh
everyone's moved out of New York people
are missing people and this level of mid
to senior seems to be where the biggest
ghost has happened so how can we find
mid to seniors that want to meet more
people and say we represent them and
know the best ones we found out by being
curious how how long did it take to get
your first invoice out
uh
before we went to be fair that's kind of
what led us there but
um the big one that we've yeah I guess
one that was like north of a 40K deal
kind of thing which in the US a lot of
them end up being
um nine months nine months yeah slow
game I seem yeah we got lots of
freelance things and we kind of got in
and had the odd five ten Grand sort of
thing and then to land a 50 odd K deal
yeah
um which is all about timing and that
kind of stuff it was yeah about nine
months
yeah and then now just gonna put a lot
more resource energy into it well now
thanks for asking uh we have uh some
rules open at the moment so
um yeah we're looking we want to hire
three people I'm gonna put a post out
whenever this goes out after then
um about hiring three senior recruiters
we we did look to hire somebody locally
in the US and we did uh experiment with
a couple of people that just didn't work
yeah
um why because
our culture and our brand and how we
operate as you've heard is like is our
USP to just Outsource that to someone in
the US it's just not going to work so we
want to incubate three people in the UK
get them to know everything that we know
about the creative Market country
agnostically
um it's a weird term isn't it
internationally yeah uh and
and once they've got that they either
can move to the us we'll be incorporated
by them have visas and that sort of
thing set up or they can stay in the UK
and work the U.S market that's a lot of
people do that yeah which is that it's
not unheard of so um yeah we're looking
for three senior they can or cannot have
worked or haven't worked in the um the
UK Market in creative and whatever it'd
be great if it were to the US market the
more important thing is that they're
curious about the creative Industries
and want to learn more about it because
hey if you didn't know there's a million
jobs being added to this industry in the
next five years so it's a boomy Market
yeah let's go thank you it's been a
pleasure thanks for being honest sharing
you know a ton of things that I think a
lot of Founders recruiters will find
helpful so that's gone on the Pod thanks
for having me